but i'm always amazed that you know
people have said to me and i had to kind
of agree it we're like oh what a
terrible year and then they go
yeah and it went so fast and it kind of
did
and i and i thought to myself yeah you
know when i'm a hundred
if i live that long i'm going to
remember this year
it was terrible but it was memorable and
it was not like anything else so
i i made a little video to myself
to future me because you know what i'm
giving you
when i don't know so so i made it for
myself to remind myself of what this
year was when i'm 100.
but i thought i'd show it to you would
you like to see it it's
okay well this is a retrospective and
it's just a
little video i made to my
hundred-year-old self
hey there future me if you're watching
this
congratulations on making it to a
hundred
soon you'll be old enough to watch fox
news
anyway i'm reaching out to you because i
figure out a hundred after all the pot
we smoked
your mind must be like soup would you
probably have some on your shirt right
now
but look if there ever was a year that
people are going to want to hear about
it's the famous plague year of 2020 and
bill
you live through it you're going i say
you're going to
want to remember some of this because it
was a pretty special time
in march we got locked inside everybody
all the time
and let me tell you we may not have had
toilet paper
but we had a raw determination to get
back on the air
and your intrepid producers came through
and put the home
back in home box office thank god for
backyards and man caves
you used every square inch of your home
your own home at first shooting the
whole show on nothing but an iphone
you interviewed senators congressmen and
mayors from a chair in front of a cut
out of trump
giving the finger and two feet away from
a stripper bowl
this really happened there were lots of
challenges
technical weather
doing your own makeup but always wearing
a fresh suit
just like you always had in the studio
so people out there would know
you virus but the big one
how do you do monologue comedy when you
had no audience
[Music]
bill you son of a you got super
high one night and figured it out
[Applause]
finally after five months he got back to
the studio and just in time to see
joe biden get elected and trump refused
to leave something the pundit said no
one could have predicted
i i don't see him leaving willingly if i
don't see him leaving
he is not going to leave oh i'm the guy
who says he's not leaving he's not going
to leave even if he loses
i don't think he's leaving he's not
going to leave
he's not leaving i don't think he's
leaving i'm right
and you won't leave but he's not leaving
he's not going to leave
he's not leaving he's not going to leave
well old timer i hope that trump or even
more dreadfully one of his offspring
isn't president of your watching this
most of all
i hope you remember how grateful you
were
to the entire intrepid unbreakable staff
at real time
for pulling miracles out of their ass
every week
and to the folks at home for letting us
do what we do
keep both sides honest in good times and
bad
even when the audience wasn't really
there
you knew they were there and you were
there for them
[Applause]
[Music]
okay what a year
crazy
you